All right.
So, J.P. gave you a very good summary of
what the options are, available to you.
When you use firebases rules and
security language But,
what do these rules actually look like.
Before we dive into validation,
let's take a quick look at how
these rules are structured.
You already saw an example of what
rules look like ,when we looked at
the dashboard before.
In fact clicking here, is where
you'll need to go to edit your rules.
Once you're in the Security & Rules tab,
you could write your rules here and
save them using this button.
Any changes that you save,
will immediately affect any read or
write calls sent to
your Firebase database.
These rules should also look
familiar from when in Version 0.4,
we talked about using index on and
value rules, okay.
So, here are the default rules,
the rules themselves are adjacent,
which look similar to your
firebase database itself.
There are string key value pairs,
which are separated by colons nd
everything that's considered
an object or list.
Is surrounded by curly braces,
as seen here, remember that these
strings are enclosed in quotes.
If you're not super familiar with
this sort of adjacent syntax,
I've provided a link to
a sample rules file.
That you could look at to
base your rule syntax off of.
So, what are these rules doing?
Well, these are the simplest
of simple list rules,
your rules file will always start
with this rules object here.
And then usually,
the children inside of it mirror
the structure of your actual database.
In this case, these rules are providing
access to the entire database,
no matter what the structure
happens to be.
It's read and write viewable and
there are no validation rules, so
there aren't any structural
constraints here.
Including these two rules
is actually important,
because by default access
to the data is false.
So, you do need these rules to
explicitly say, that read is true for
the whole database and
right is true for the whole database.
Because if I actually deleted this and
saved it, by default,
nobody would be able to write anything
to the database but I would do that.
Normally your rules are going to
mirror your database structure.
So for example, if I wanted to
write some rules to validate
the structure of my user node,
I might write something like this.
As you can see here, I've got
the exact route name of the user and
here, I've got the key names
embedded of all the properties.
So your key names here need to match
exactly what's shown in your database
and they need to be nested
in exactly the same way.
Now, you might be wondering what
this key here is all about.
the dollar sign followed by a word,
indicates what is noted firebase
as a wildcard variable.
Now wildcard variables have
a couple different uses but
the most common one is,
to represent dynamic keys like push ids.
And in this case, user emails,
because remember,
under the user node is
a list of user emails.
The keys of which we
can't guess in advance.
Now, once you've laid
out this structure,
you can start defining rules for
the user object.
When you want to write a rule for
a particular location, you go to
the location in your rules file that
mirrors the location in your database.
And this is your first
example of a rule,
the Kiva rule is always a dot read,
dot write or dot validate value.
And the value of a rule
will always be something
that evaluates to a boolean and
this is important.
Because when a user tries to read or
write at that location,
the value of this boolean affects
whether they're actually able to do so.
Now, these expressions that evaluate
to billions can get pretty complicated,
they can include comparison and
logical operators.
And Firebase also provides
additional methods and
internal preset variables that allow you
to get a value at the current location.
Or compare to other
locations of the database.
For example, there are methods that let
you look at the data at children and
parent locations of
your current location.
So if necessary,
you could do comparisons between
the value of name of the value of email.
Or even the value of name and
someplace totally else in the database.
Okay, so
once you've written this out and
you actually start to try to read or
write data at certain locations.
All of the applicable rules along the
path to that location, will be checked.
Validate and write rules are checked
whenever a value is written, and
read rules are checked whenever
listeners are attached.
For example,
if I try to write in this location,
with a value Lyla, any rules that
are at the lylafish@gmail.com location.
Which is this variable here,
there aren't any rules here, and
at the name location,
which has one validate rule here.
So total, because this is a right,
these two rules would be checked,
now let's pretend that this
right rule wasn't here.
This was actually the rule that was
giving me the ability to write to
this location.
So if you ever tried to
do something like that,
where you don't have permission to
do the action that you want to do.
The on cancel callback method Will
be triggered in your code, and
it will be given a FirebaseError Of
type PERMISSION_DENIED.
All right, I've just thrown in
lot of information at you, so
let me take a moment to summarize.
Your rules file as found in the firebase
dashboard in the security and
rules tab and the rules
themselves are written in JSON.
The actual permissions will have keys
that are .right, .read or .validate and
they will always have values that
evaluate to either true or false.
If there is no read or
write rule at a location or
its parent locations,
then it will default to false.
When you are writing your permission
rule, you'll place it in the rules
location that mirrors the database
location that you're interested in.
If a user tries to do something that
is not allowed by the read, write or
validate rules.
The FirebaseError will
be returned to them and
its value will be Permission_Denied.
Okay, and those are basically the facts
that you need to get started.
So go ahead and we'll start
laying out some of these rules.